>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> FORMER TRUMP LAWYER JOHN
EASTMAN NOW REVEALING THAT
FEDERAL AGENTS SEIZED HIS PHONE
THEY INVESTIGATE HIS ROLE IN
EFFORTS TO TRY TO OVERTURN THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
OUR CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
RYAN NOBLES IS JOINING US.
>> CAPITOL HILL.
SO, RYAN, TELL VIEWERS WHAT YOU
ARE LEARNING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, WOLF.
THIS MARKS INCREASE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
RESULTS BY -- THIR INVESTIGATING
JOHN EASTMAN, THE CONSERVATIVE
LAWYER AT THE CENTER OF THAT
EFFORT TO TRY TO PRESSURE MIKE
PENCE TO STOOND IN THE WAY OF
ELECTION RESULTS.
EASTMAN IS CLAIMING THE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS OF THE FBI STOPPED
HIM WHEN HE WAS LEAVE WITH A
RESTAURANT WITH HIS WIFE AND
FRIEND, ASK THEN AKED FOR ACCESS
HIS PHONE.
THAT MEANS THEY WERE ABLE TO
SEIZE THE PHONE AND THAT MEANS
THE INFORMATION ON THAT PHONE IS
PART OF THEIR INVESTIGATION.
NOW, EASTMAN BELIEVES THAT
SEIZURE WAS ILLEGAL.
HE IS COMPLAINING ABOUT IT.
THAT'S HOW WE LEARNED THROUGH
THIS, THROUGH A COURT FILING.
NOW, THE INTEREST FROM EASTMAN
KMZ AS THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS ANNOUNCED PLANS
FOR AUDIO SURPRISE HEARING THAT
IS SCHEDULED TO PLACE TOMORROW.
YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT LAST
WEEK, THE COMMITTEE SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK IN
THE HEARING SCHEDULE, AND NOT
PICK UP AGAIN UNTIL THE MIDDLE
OF JULY.
WELL, THAT CHANGED TO THE
AFTERNOON MANY THEY ANNOUNCED
THEY HAD A WITNESS TO BRING TO
THE PUBLIC TO SHARE WHAT THEY
KNOW ABOUT THAT INVESTIGATION.
AT THIS POINT, WOLF, WE DO NOT
KNOW WHO THAT IS BUT IT SUGGESTS
THAT THE INFORMATION IS
SIGNIFICANT.
WOLF.
>> IS THERE A SENSE, RYAN, THIS
NEWLY OBTAINED BY THE SELECT
COMMITTEE COULD BE TIME
SENSITIVE?
>> IT CERTAIN SEEMS TO HAVE ALL
THE MARKINGS OF THAT WOLF.
AS WE SAID BEFORE, THE COMMITTEE
PLA H PLANS TO TAKE A STEP BACK.
THEY WERE COLLECTING NEW
INFORMATION THAT CAME IN AS A
RESULT OF THE FIRST ROUND OF
HEARINGS.
THEY WEREN'T PLANTING TO HAVE
ANYTHING ADDITIONALLY BE DONE
UNTIL JULY AND MOST MEMBERS HAVE
LEFT TOWN.
THE JULY 4 RECESS IS IN EFFECT
FOR MEMBERS OF DON'T GUESS.
WE ARE THOU TOLD THESE MEMBERS
ARE MAKING THEIR WAY BACK TO
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO BE PART OF
THIS SURPRISE, WHAT MANY MIGHT
DESCRIBE AS AN EMERGENCY
HEARING.
IT MAKES IT SEEM AS IF-LET
INFORMATION THEY WANT TO DELIVER
TOMORROW MORNING DOES HAVE A
DEGREE OF TIME SENSITIVITY TO
IT.
>> RYAN, I WANT YOU TO STAND BY.
I WANT TO BRING IN AM FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR AN ANDREW McCABE AND
MAGGIE HABERMAN-LET WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT FOR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
ANDREW, THE FBI AGENTS SEIZED
EASTMAN'S PHONE AS HE WAS
WALKING OUT OF A RESTAURANT.
MADE HIM UP LOCK IT.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
THIS INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, I MAIN, IT -- IT'S YET
ANOTHER SIGNAL THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION IS WELL DEVELOPED
AND STILL IN A VERY DYNAMIC
STAGE.
LET'S REMEMBER, WOLF, IN ORDER
TO GET A SEARCH WARRANT WHICH
SHE HAD TO SEIZE THIS PHONE,
THOSE AGENTS HAD TO, FIRST, GO
TO A FEDERAL JUDGE ASK CONVINCE
A FEDERAL JUDGE THAT THEY HAD
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE THERE
WAS EVIDENCE A CRIME ON THAT
PHONE.
THE EXECUTION OF THAT WARRANT ON
MR. EASTMAN AS A LEFT A
RESTAURANT IS A LITTLE BIT
CONVENTIONAL BUT THE REASON
GETTING HANDS ON THE PHONE RIGHT
NOW IS BECAUSE WE KNOW MR.
EASTMAN AND OTHERS INVOLVED IN
THIS CONSPIRACY UTILIZED
ENCRYPTED PLATFORMS LIKE SIGNAL
AND WHATSAPP DOES THING LIKES
THAT SO THE ONLY WAY TO GET
CONTENT FROM THE MESSAGES IS TO
HAVE AN ACTUAL PHONE THE
MESSAGES WERE SENT TO.
SO THIS COULD GIVE PROSECUTORS A
EAT GREAT DEGREE OF VISIBILITY
TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
>> YEAH.
VERY DRAMATIC.
ITTED HAPPENED ON THE SAME DAY,
A SENIOR-JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL, JEFFREY CLARK, HIS
HOME RAIDED APPROXIMATE BY THE
FBI AELZ.
HOW SIGNIFICANT KNOWING EASTMAN
FOR EXAMPLE WAS IN CONTACT WITH
THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP AROUND KEY
MOMENTS AROUND JANUARY 6th?
ZBLEL, LOOK AS ANDREW SAID, YOU
KNOW, HS SHOWING THERE IS AN
ACTIVE INVESTIGATION INVOLVED.
THE FACT THERE WAS SUCH AN
AGGRESSIVE STEP TAKEN TO GET
THIS DEVICE WHILE ACCORDING TO
HIM, HE WAS LEAVING A
RESTAURANT, PAINTS QUITE A SCENE
OF A SENSE OF URGENCY.
AGAIN, WHETHER IT GOES, HOW MUCH
FOCUS THEY ARE PUTTING ON
FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP, I DON'T
THINK WE ARE GOING TO KNOW FOR A
LITTLE PIT OF TIME BUT CLEARLY
AT LEAST ONE ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION GOING INTO EVENTS
RELATED TO JANUARY 6th.
>> CERTAINLY DOES.
YOU KNOW, ANDREW, THIS COMES AS
SELECT COMMITTEE SUDDENLY TODAY
ADDED A HEARING TOMORROW WHEN,
ORIGINALLY, THERAPY SUPPOSED TO
BE TAKING A BREAK UNTIL NEXT
MONTH.
SO WHAT NEW EVIDENCE OR
TESTIMONY WOULD WARRANT A SUDDEN
ANNOUNCEMENT LIKE THIS?
>> GREAT QUESTION WOLF AND I
WISH I HAD THE ANSWER FOR IT.
BUT I TELL YOU WHAT WE IT KNOW.
WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
VERY FOCUSED IN TELLING A STORY
IN A COMPELLING AND ENGROSSING
WAY.
WE ALSO KNOW THEY CREATED A FAIR
AMOUNT OF MOMENTUM LAST HEARING,
LAST THURSDAY, ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION KPERMT EXERTED ON
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
MY GUESS SQUSH AND IT IS PURELY
A GUESS -- AND IS THAT RUSHING
THIS HEARING ONTO THE SCHEDULE
NOW INDICATES THAT WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO PRESENT TOMORROW,
EITHER IN THE FORM OF -- OF A
EVIDENCE OR WITNESS TESTIMONY,
IS RELATIVE TO WHAT THEY
PRESENTED ON THURSDAY.
A TOIMGZ OF THAT SAME STORY.
IT'S LIKE THEY WANT TO KEEP THAT
MOMENTUM GOING TO KIND OF CLOSE
OUT THIS STORY IN ITS FINALITY.
OR POTENTIALLY, A WITNESS.
SOMEONE, WHO MAYBE WAS TALKED
ABOUT AT THE HEARING LAST WEEK
ASK NOW CHANGED THEIR MIND AND
DECIDED TO COME BE QUESTIONED.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO SAY BUT
PROBABLY RELATED TO LAST WEEK'S
TESTIMONY.
>> COULD BE DRAMATIC INCLEED.
MAG DPI, GIVEN THE METHODICAL
WAY THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAS
APPROACHED ALL THIS SO FAR, ARE
YOU SURPRISED THEY WOULD
ANNOUNCE A NEW HEARING ON SUCH
SHORT NOTICE?
>> I THINK WE ALL WERE SURPRISED
RGTS WOLF, THEY WERE ANNOUNCING
THIS IN SUCH A DRAMATIC FASHION.
THERE IS ONE OTHER PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT THE COMMITTEE
GOT HOLD OF LAST WEEK AND THAT
IS THESE 11-OR-SO HOURS OF FILM
FROM A DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER WHO
WAS SPENDING TIME AROUND THE
TRUMP FAMILY AND SOME TIME
AROUND FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIMSELF IN THE IMMEDIATE LEAD-UP
TO THE ELECTION AND THE PERIOD
AFTERWARDS AND THEY WERE LOOKING
AT ALL OF THE FILM.
LOOKING AT THE INTERVIEWS.
THERE WERE THREE FILMMAKER THE
FILMMAKER DID WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND SO IT
ALSO COULD RELATE TO THAT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OPTIONS,
HOWEVER THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
DRAMATIC PILD UP, AND SO IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
EMERGES.
>> CERTAINLY WILL BE, ASK WE
WILL APPROXIMATE WATCHING EVERY
MOMENT OF THAT.
RYAN, DOES ANNOUNCING A HEARING
ON SUCH SHORT NOTICE RAISE THE
STAKES FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
ACTUALLY DELIVER -- YOU ARE UP
THERE AN COP TOLL HILL?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
DOUBT ABOUT THAT, WOLF.
THE WAY THIS HAS GONE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THINK MADE SUCH
A BIG DEAL RAISES THE STAKE
FORCE IT HEARING TOMORROW AND
THEY REALLY DO HAVE TO DELIVER
PAUSE A BIG PART OF WHAT COMITE
SE IS TRYING TO DO IS WIN IN THE
COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION AND PUT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE
ACTION ON WHAT THEY UNCOVERED IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
AND I DO THINK PART OF THIS WOLF
IS I THINK THE COMMITTEE, TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT, HAS BEEN
SURPRISED BY THE AMOUNT OF NEW
INFORMATION THAT HAS BEEN
GENERATEDPY WITNESSES AND OTHER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN WATCHING
THESE HEARINGS AND IT'S EITHER
JOGGED THEIR MEMORY OR PERHAPS
CONVINCED THEM THEY NEED TO BE A
PART OF THAT INVESTIGATION AND
CONTRIBUTE WHAT THEY KNOW.
SO THERE IS ALSO A DISTINCT
POSSIBILITY THAT WHAT WE SAW
TOMORROW IS SOMEONE WHO'S COME
FORWARD AFTER SEEING SOMEONE
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE IN THESE
HEARINGS SAYING I HAVE AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF INFORMATION
TO ADD.
AGAIN, THEY ARE KEEPING SUCH A
TIGHT LID ON IT.
WE MAY NOT KNOW UNTIL THEY GAVEL
IN TOMORROW AT 1:00 EASTERN.
>> I COULD BE LONG.
ANDREW, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FLURRY ACTIVITY NOW COMING FROM
THE U.S. JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AT
THE SAME TIME THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IS HOLDING THESE
PUBLIC HEARINGS?
IS THERE ANYTHING TO THAT
TIMELING?
TIMING?
>> WOLF, I THINK THE TIMING WAS
A BIT OF UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR DOJ BECAUSE
PEOPLE QUITE NATURALLY TRY TO
LINK THE TWO.
THE SEARCH WARRANT ON JEFFREY
CLARK'S HOME AND NOW WE KNOW THE
SEARCH WARRANT ON EASTMAN'S
PHONE AND ALL HEAPING AROUND THE
TIME OF LAST WEEK'S HEARING.
IT IS MORE LIKELY THEY ARE JUST
AT THAT POINT IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION, WHERE THEY ARE
READY TO TAKE SOME OVERT STEPS,
LIKE EXECUTING SEARCH WARRANTS
WHICH, AT THAT POINT, THE GIG IS
UP, RIGHT?
THE PUBLIC KNOWS THESE PEOPLE
ARE UNDER INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT SIGNALS A VERY PROFOUND
TURN IN THE INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THAT TIMING PROBABLY
JUST HAPPENED TO COINCIDE LAST
WEEK'S HEARING BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE'LL NEVER KNOW.
>> ALWAYS SENSITIVE TO GET A
SERP SEARCH WARR